Las Vegas continues to grow and people
are noticing one area in particular a
shopping district located near Craig and
Rancho 8 news now reporter Madison
Kimbrough was there and spoke with those
living in the area
[Music]
this vacant lot has a lot of potential
for new development as more and more
restaurants and retail outlets are
popping up in this Northwest area of the
valley
I still think it's very enjoyable and a
good place to be I'm just curious to see
how far they go Jennifer Gibson moved to
Las Vegas last year and since then she's
noticed this area of Craig and Rancho
evolving in the Northwest Valley and she
wonders what could pop up next we came
from California about a year ago and so
I really had enjoyed how wide open the
space was I think some of it is a good
thing a little bit of the other is
starting to feel a little crowded what
used to be a Kmart building which closed
down many years ago is now a new
furniture store with a Planet Fitness a
couple doors down and Dutch Bros across
the street some pleased with the
continued growth even if it does slow
down their morning commute I think it's
really great it's developing pretty
vastly
um sure there is a lot more traffic so I
do have to wake up a little bit earlier
every day for work and others understand
that with growth comes a price tag but
ultimately feel like it's needed to keep
the economy afloat I'm all four new
people moving in it's just when it comes
to moving in I think it can make things
a bit more expensive but either way I
mean people have to have a place to live
this area is just a mile up the road
from where Texas Station and Fiesta
Rancho used to sit which offered a
variety of amenities with Station
Casinos having knocked down their
properties people who live nearby are
looking for what's next Costco's my
family's from the Middle East so I mean
a lot of more Middle Eastern foods and
um I would say shops would be pretty
nice as for Boulevard home the sign on
the door states that it will be opening
next month reporting near Craig and
Rancho Madison Kimbrough 8 news now now
along with the new businesses opening up
in the area new homes are being built
near the Craig and Rancho retail lot as
well